general elections are supposed to happen
every five years but this is the third
one since 2015 so why is it happening
when Theresa May became prime minister
after David Cameron stepped down she
promised her government would deliver
brexit but with a slender majority of
only 12 in the House of Commons she went
back to the country in 2017 to win more
seats for the Conservatives and bolster
her brexit negotiating position strong
and stable strong and stable strong and
stable
she made a gamble and it backfired
spectacularly instead of strengthening
her position she lost her majority her
brexit plans were voted down three times
she faced repeated calls to resign from
within her own party and by the summer
of 2019 it was clear she could no longer
lead it's been the honor of my life to
have had the opportunity to serve the
country I love
Boris Johnson won the contest to replace
her he tried to suspend Parliament for
five weeks limiting the amount of time
MPs would have to scrutinize his brexit
strategy but the highest court in the
land said this was unlawful as it
prevented debate around his policy
strongly disagree with what the justices
have found I don't think that it's right
meanwhile 21 conservative MPs rebelled
against the prime minister voting
against him to stop the threat of a No
Deal brexit they were suspended from the
party
[Applause]
Boris Johnson was now well short of a
parliamentary majority he could have
tried to govern as Prime Minister until
2022 but instead he's called for an
early general election hoping to
reshuffle the arithmetic in Parliament
and win more conservative MPs that will
back his brexit plan labour the Liberal
Democrats and the Scottish National
Party signed up for the election but
only once the immediate threat of a No
Deal brexit was off the table so finally
the December election was agreed and the
country must vote for its third
Parliament in five years
[Music]